since we have a panel we can do many
issues and this week as I mentioned in
the monologue we got back to normal and
when I say normal I mean ugly racial
incidents preceded by Joe Biden at the
beginning of the week having a
controversy where he said if you have a
problem figuring out whether to vote for
me or Donald Trump you ain't black
now I actually must tell you I hate it
when people use that sort of phrase if
you don't agree with this opinion I have
then you ain't this thing you ain't a
woman you in an American you ain't a
patriot I'm not for that but at Kanye
West for example don't agree with him on
Trump but I loved it when he said the
mob can't make me hate him love that but
it's also true now we saw this incident
I mentioned it in the monologue about
the person who was George Florida's his
name a black man who was killed by this
white police officer in Minneapolis a
replay of the Eric garner incident
somewhat just it could have stopped the
crowds yelling at him unbelievable Trump
is all in on the cops and the cops let's
be honest almost all of them are all in
on Trump in that light I kind of
understand what Joe Biden is saying why
would a black person vote for Donald
Trump
yes except he didn't say that right he
said it in an awkward lame way and he
apologized which she should have done
and I think the fact that it you know
he's held to a higher standard so the
story goes on and on and on and you know
where's dong Trump lies constantly and
and it's sort of normalized all the time
but yeah I mean he could have said in a
more articulate way America is very
racist and in fact we have a huge
problem with white supremacy and
sometimes that plays out in policing
frequently and so while people look at
these individual cases of George Floyd a
Calandra Casteel Sandra bland of air
garner they're not really individuals
right it's a systemic problem that
people don't necessarily want to figure
out how to to tackle it's not
individuals it's a system and by the way
I would throw in you know dog lady in
Central Park Amy Cooper right she's part
of that same conversation because what
she was doing very clearly oh as she
approached this murder guy Chris Cooper
right was saying listen I can weaponize
the fact that if I saw the police on the
phone african-american man is
threatening me that's gonna trigger
something and I can I can leverage that
and I can use that and I can use that
power against you and that's the America
we live in so I wish I didn't hadn't
said that because it's like you say look
I hate when people say those things it's
stupid and he apologized and I wish
everybody would move on and focus on
other things but I don't think there's a
huge number of black people who are
supporting Donald Trump if you look at
the polls you know that some but it's
not a lot yeah I think you know when
Trump told the black people what do you
have to lose you know why wouldn't you
vote for me everything's gone so bad
well it's been four years now and I
think they actually have some experience
with what they have to lose under four
more years yeah so I mean you know Biden
can can make some really awkward
statements but I don't think Biden's in
any danger of losing the black vote to
our present president yeah it's it's a
shame because when you look at this
situation you mentioned the the Cooper's
they're both named Cooper the people in
Central Park if people weren't following
this closely there's a birdwatcher
an african-american guide named
Christian Cooper he's a birdwatcher and
Amy Cooper is a white lady dog walker
and no relation no relation it's it's if
there wasn't the ugly racial part of it
it could be a meet-cute for a rom-com it
really could two people named Cooper a
dog walker and a birdwatcher meet in the
park but here's the interesting thing I
want to ask about she is an Obama
donating Democrat Amy Cooper so so white
liberal ladies can be racist well that's
my question is a lot of people think
that way sir certainly conservatives
feel I know talking to them often that
liberals are phony about issues like
this that's one thing they don't like
about liberals they say well you scold
us for things like using oil but you use
oil you scold us for being elitist you
bribe your kids into college you scold
us for being racist but you take
advantage even if you're not racist in
the park of racial inequities in hiring
and jobs and lots housing and lots of
stuff and in this case it's gonna look
to a lot of people yes
like white liberalism is this they're my
on camera on Zoom it's very thin very
thin is that is that what you're saying
caliber there are plenty of white
liberal people who are racist and I
think Amy I know idea about her
political leanings but I'm not surprised
at all she's a New York City walking her
dog I am not surprised and by the way I
think if you call it up black people
that you I was gonna say bump into on
the street but we're not doing that
anymore that you call up on zoom' calls
they would tell you yeah they work with
lots of white liberal people who also
were racist so it's not a surprise and I
think it's just a mistake to think that
white liberal ladies can't be can't be
racist I think we should just understand
that the reason why Trump was elected
and the reason why there is such
incredible polarization in society right
now is because the top 10% of earners in
the United States
have been so focused on ensuring that
they not only maintain but also extend
the privilege and for me the scandal
that really summarized all of this was
varsity blues and all of these very
wealthy people that were doing
everything possible to ensure that their
kids not deserve and found a way to get
into those best schools and when I saw
the Greenwich Connecticut that 50% of
high schoolers taking the SAT out of
Greenwich had letters from doctors that
allowed them to take it with no time
restrictions unmonitored that's not just
rigged I mean that is the system that's
structural that's if you have any
capacity that's what you're gonna do and
I think that comes in every shape and
every form but we know what it's about
and this this Central Park incident was
enough yet another reflection and
everyone on the wrong side of that said
yep we know we know it that's about
caring structural is the key word right
so it's structurally it's beyond even
liberal or conservative it is the
structure of how historically white
women and there's a five kajillion
examples of this had been able to
leverage some power against somebody
black men I mean I think the thing that
I found most interesting about Amy
Cooper was this idea that she she makes
it so clear great and she gets on the
phone and says an african-american man
is threatening me she knows exactly what
buttons she's pressing in order to get
the police to respond a certain way away
that could have ended up like you know
mr. Floyd so yeah I don't think it
matters whether she's a you know writing
checks to you know liberal causes or
whatever I'm not surprised at all